DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
IT'S THE BATTLE OF THE
BILLIONAIRES AND NOW IT IS MIKE
BLOOMBERG'S TURN.
HE USED TO BE REPUBLICAN BUT HE
BECAME SO RICH HE HAD TO JOIN
THE DEMOCRATS.
HE IS RICH, WHITE, MALE, AND IN
CNN TERMS, HE IS SAFE.
NOW HE BLOW BEATS IN THE FACES
OF OTHER DEMS, OFFERING TO THEM
BASED ON HIS DECADES OF SUCCESS
AS WELL AS BEING BORING AND
EARNEST.
SPEAKING IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, HE
REMINDS THE DEMS THAT THE
ELECTION TAKES PLACE IN AMERICA,
NOT BERKELEY.
THE DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGN
RESEMBLES A HIGH SCHOOL BEER
PARTY BEFORE MOM AND DAD SHOW
UP.
>> I AM TIRED OF LISTENING TO
THINGS THAT ARE PIE-IN-THE-SKY,
THAT WE ARE NEVER GOING TO PASS,
NEVER GOING TO AFFORD.
>> PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO GIVE
UP THEIR JOBS IF THOSE JOBS
HABITS NOT THE ON THE RIGHT SIDE
OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
I THINK YOU CAN HAVE MEDICARE
FOR ALL FOUR PEOPLE THAT ARE
UNCOVERED TO REPLACE THE ENTIRE
PRIVATE SYSTEM WHERE COMPANIES P
PRIVATE SYSTEM WHERE COMPANIES O
PRIVATE SYSTEM WHERE COMPANIES I
PRIVATE SYSTEM WHERE COMPANIES E
HEALTH CARE FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES
WOULD BANKRUPT US FOR A VERY
LONG TIME.
>> Greg: TALK ABOUT CHARISMA.
OR THE OPPOSITE OF CHARISMA.
DON'T HAVE HIM STAND IN FRONT OF
MACHINES.
HE JUST BLENDS IN.
BLOOMBERG IS CALLING B.S. ON ITS
OWN SIDE, OFFERING A REALITY
CHECK TO A PARTY OF DOPEY
HISTORY.
THAT MAKES TWO BILLIONAIRES.
HIM AND SHELTERING COLD WATER ON
THE BOZOS.
THIS IS A PARTY TIED IN KNOTS
WITH THE LOUDEST VOICES
EMBRACING BAD IDEAS THAT LEFT
BEHIND A CENTURIES WORTH OF
SKULLS.
AS PROGRESSIVES, AREN'T THEY
SUPPOSED TO LOOK FORWARD
INCIDENT DRESSING UP AS LENIN?
THEY LOOK AT THIS COUNTRY AND
THEY SAY I'M TIRED OF THIS
PROSPERITY.
LET'S DESTROY THE GREATEST
SYSTEM EVER CREATED AND REPLACE
IT WITH A THING THAT ALWAYS
FAILS WHICH IS WHY GLOOMY
REMINDS PEOPLE THAT SOCIALISM
ISN'T SOME COOL NEW THING, A
HIP TEACHER TOLD YOU ABOUT TO
GET YOU TO SHARE HIS LONG IN A
VAN BEHIND THE FOOTBALL FIELD.
>> WE NEED A HEALTHY ECONOMY.
WE SHOULDN'T BE EMBARRASSED
ABOUT OUR SYSTEM.
IF YOU WANT TO LOOK AT A SYSTEM
THAT'S NONCAPITALIST IT, TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT WAS PERHAPS THE
WEALTHIEST COUNTRY IN THE WORLD
AND TODAY PEOPLE ARE STARVING TO
DEATH.
IT'S CALLED VENEZUELA.
>> Greg: SOUNDS LIKE HE IS
HANDING SOME COMMON SENSE TO THE
DEMS, LIKE FEEDING STEAK TO A
CATFISH.
WHEN I WAS WRITING THIS, I
DIDN'T ACTUALLY LISTEN TO THE
TAPE, KATIE.
I READ HIS QUOTES.
HE'S -- THESE ARE GOOD QUOTES.
HE IS A SMART DUDE.
THEN I LISTEN TO HIM AND SAY NO.
HE'S NOT MAKING IT.
>> Dana: IT WOULD BE NICE IF
YOU COULD PUT YOURSELF ON 1.5
SPEED.
>> Katie: HE IS NOT GOING WITH
THE BOMBASTIC NICKNAMES, NOT THE
CORY BOOKER STYLE SPARTACUS
MOVES.
I'M NOT SURE HE'S GOING TO MAKE
IT BUT I DO LIKE WHAT HE IS
SAYING ABOUT DEMOCRATS.
HE HAD THINGS TO SAY ABOUT
VENEZUELA AND THE SOCIALISM WE
ARE SEEING THERE.
TODAY ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
ATTACKED HOWARD SCHULTZ FOR
BEING A BILLIONAIRE AND SAYING
THAT HE NEEDS TO GET IN LINE.
IT'S FUNNY HOW THE LEFT LIKES
BILLIONAIRES WHEN IT'S
CONVENIENT, LIKE DONATIONS TO
THEIR CAMPAIGN, GEORGE SOROS
FUNDING ALL OF THESE ADVOCACY
GROUPS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR SUCCESS
IN THE DREAM AND BUILDING COMES
UP FROM THE BOTTOM AS HOWARD
SCHULTZ DID, GREW UP IN BROOKLYN
HOUSING PROJECT AND MADE HIS WAY
TO STARBUCKS.
>> Dana: GET IN LINE IS WHAT
DEMOCRAT SAID ABOUT ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
SHE DID HANDILY BEAT THE
CONGRESSMAN WHO DIDN'T SHOW UP
TO HIS OWN DEBATE.
>> Greg: BLOOMBERG WAS A
PRETTY GOOD MAYOR, WRITES?
>> Dana: COMPARED TO NOW, YEAH
YEAH.
>> Greg: ARE ROCK THAT YOU
FOUND AT THE BOTTOM OF A
TOILET."
>> Dana: PEOPLE ARE HIRING
PRIVATE SECURITY TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES ON THE UPPER WEST
SIDE.
COME ON.
>> Jesse: IS THAT WHAT YOUR
PILATES TEACHER TOLD YOU.
>> Dana: NO, BUT HE TOLD ME
SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK SOMEBODY
LIKE HIM IS GOING TO MAKE ANY
HEADWAY?
>> Dana: I THINK THE HEADWAY
HE MAKES IS BY -- WITHIN THE
PARTY.
I DON'T THINK HE GOES TO THE
FRONT OF THE PACK IS THE
ULTIMATE NOMINEE BUT CAN
SOMEBODY LIKE HOWARD SCHULTZ OR
MIKE BLOOMBERG GET THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, KEEP THEM FROM
GOING SO FAR LEFT THAT IT'S
UNRECOGNIZABLE.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK,
JUAN?
DO YOU THINK HE HAS A CHANCE?
WILL ANYBODY LISTEN TO HIM?
WHOEVER IS KIND OF TRUMPIAN,
CHARISMATIC, MEMORABLE IS GOING
TO BE WHO'S GOING TO BE THE
NOMINEE?
>> Juan: PEOPLE LIKE THE FACT
THAT MIKE BLOOMBERG IS A
THOUGHTFUL GUY AND HE HAS A LOT
OF MONEY OBVIOUSLY SO WE CAN
FUND HIS OWN CAMPAIGN.
HE'S GOING TO GET LOTS OF
PLATFORMS.
YOU SAW HIM IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
NO QUESTION HE'S GOING TO BE OUT
THERE.
HE IS KNOWN, THE NEW YORK MEDIA
LIKES HIM.
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE.
THE ISSUE IS WHETHER OR NOT A
BILLIONAIRE IN AN ERA OF
TREMENDOUS INCOME INEQUALITY IS
IN TOUCH WITH THE REAL ISSUES
FACING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I WAS LOOKING TODAY.
SOMETHING LIKE WAS IT HUGE
NUMBER, 57% OF AMERICANS CAN'T
AFFORD A $500 BILL IN 2019.
THERE IS POPULISM, TRUMP SIDE.
THE POPULISM ON THE FAR RIGHT
AND THE FAR LEFT.
BERNIE SANDERS, DONALD TRUMP.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT.
I THINK HE'S OUT OF TOUCH WITH
THAT.
THE CRITICISM OF MEDICARE FOR
ALL WHICH IS COMING FROM KAMALA
HARRIS.
GUESS WHAT, MOST AMERICAN
SUPPORTED.
>> Greg: UNTIL THEY FIGURE OUT
HOW IT WORKS.
>> Juan: THEY SAY WHAT ABOUT,
CAN I KEEP THIS, WHATEVER.
THE IDEA THAT IS STARTING THE
DISCUSSION IS SUPPORTED BY MOST
AMERICANS, INCLUDING MOST
REPUBLICANS.
>> Greg: THAT'S A HALF
OPINION.
THE OTHER HALF IS HOW DO YOU PAY
FOR IT.
ONCE YOU GET TO THAT, THE OTHER
OPINION GOES.
JESSE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT BLOOMBERG OR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT HOWARD
SCHULTZ?
>> Jesse: I WILL DO BOTH.
>> Greg: CAN I SHOW YOU
SOMETHING?
IT'S THIS TAPE FROM MORNING JOE.
OR WATCH WHAT THEY DID THE
HOWARD SCHULTZ.
THEY ARE TRYING TO PROTECT
KAMALA.
>> HOW MUCH DOES AN 18-OUNCE BOX
OF CHEERIOS COST?
AN 18-OUNCE BOX OF CHEERIOS.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU ASK US.
THE BUDGET FOR THE BA.
>> I DON'T EAT CHEERIOS.
>> FOR BOX.
>> Greg: BECAUSE SHE LOOKED IT
UP ON GOOGLE.
SHE DOES NOT EAT CHEERIOS FOR
BREAKFAST.
>> Jesse: AS THE REIGNING
SUPERMARKET SHUTDOWN CHAMPION,
IT WAS VERY DISAPPOINTED IN
SCHULTZ.
I BOUGHT SOME CEREAL TODAY THAT
COST $7.99.
IT WAS VERY EXPENSIVE ORGANIC
CEREAL.
I TREAT MY BODY LIKE IT SHOULD
BE TREATED.
ONLY THE BEST.
HERE'S WHAT I THINK.
WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS AN
INTERVENTION.
TRUST ME.
I KNOW ABOUT INTERVENTIONS.
IT'S HAPPENED A FEW TIMES.
I KNOW IT WHEN I SEE IT.
THE CENTRISTS ARE MAKING THE
SAME ARGUMENTS THAT
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN MAKING
ABOUT SOCIALISM FOR DECADES.
THIS IS WHY IT STINGS SO MUCH.
THE DEMOCRAT RESPONSES SHUT UP,
BILLIONAIRE.
THAT'S ALL THEY HAVE.
SCHULTZ AND BLOOMBERG ARE COMING
AT THE DEMOCRATS WITH GENUINE
POLITICAL FELLOWSHIP.
THESE ERIC TRUMP HATERS.
THEY
WANT -- RUNNING ONE OF THE
BIGGEST COMPANIES IN AMERICA.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T ARGUE THE
SUBSTANCE OF THEIR POLICIES.
THEY DON'T SAY THIS HOW IT'S
GOING TO WORK AND THIS IS WHY
IT'S GOING TO WORK.
THEY SAY YOU ARE MEAN FOR
OPPOSING ME.
IT'S BAD POLITICS AND BAD POLICY
BECAUSE YOU ARE CEDING THE
ENTIRE MIDDLE OF THE COUNTRY TO
REPUBLICANS, AND REPUBLICANS
DON'T EVEN HAVE TO DO ANYTHING.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLICY OF IT,
TO SAY I WANT TO DESTROY A
TRILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY, PUT
EVERYBODY OUT OF WORK, 50% OF
THE COUNTRY GETS THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE THROUGH THEIR COMPANY
AND THEY LIKE IT.
YOU TAKE THEIR PLANS AWAY, IT'S
GOING TO BE ARMAGEDDON.
>> Greg: SCHULTZ IS ALREADY
HAVING AN EFFECT.
KAMALA IS ALREADY ADJUSTING.
SHE'S ON DEFENSE.
SHE'S CHANGING HER MIND.
I'M NOT GOING TO DITCH THE
INDUSTRY.
>> Juan: SHE NEVER SAID THAT.
>> Katie: SHE SAID ELIMINATED.
SHE SAID ELIMINATE IT.
>> Juan: THE ISSUE HERE, THE
DEFICIT HAS BALLOONED UNDER
DONALD TRUMP.
WHERE DID VULCAN